Sandra Mackey author of The Reckoning
Iraq and the legacy of Saddam Hussein on
your last page of the book page 396 you
write this an invasion of Iraq has
become almost a given in the unfolding
war on terrorism why I think there are a
variety of reasons depending on where
different people in the administration
are coming from I think certainly donald
rumsfeld sees an invasion of iraq to
reddit of saddam hussein as a way of
reducing our defense costs in the
Persian Gulf his deputy Paul Wolfowitz I
think comes at it more ideologically
that Saddam Hussein really as a threat
to the region and particularly to Israel
and therefore must go Dick Cheney I
wonder if he is wanting to finish off
the Gulf War of 91 and I think the
president has maybe a variety of reasons
I think he really does see things in in
blacks and whites and that Saddam
Hussein I think everybody agrees is a
black as far as you know the villain on
the scene the one of the black hat
riding across the range so it's you know
it's really a variety of motives of I
think certainly the conservatives in
Congress feel that the United States has
power and that we should use it and it
certain parts of the media I think share
that same opinion that America almost
the Imperial that we are the super power
and therefore power not used as power
wasted it was the last time you were in
Baghdad I was there in december of 99 i
had been there the previous year and the
reason i did not go back on a previous
on a subsequent trip was two reasons one
is it's very dangerous i mean i was
there by myself I had
no embassy I had no organization I was
connected to I was out there dangling by
myself and obviously if something
happened to me that was it you know and
you have a healthy regard for Saddam
Hussein's security services and his
presence the other reason and I think
this was probably a more compelling
reason was that what I was actually able
to accomplish I had done you know I had
been essentially all over the country I
had observed what I could observe and
you just simply cannot talk to an Iraqi
in anything but just the most
superficial terms I had had a previous
experience of doing a book on Iran and
had traveled extensively in that country
in 92 93 and 94 under the same type of
circumstances but I i went into homes I
had you know talks with people I I knew
where they were coming from and in the
Iraq of Saddam Hussein there is no
discourse there is simply the state the
security services and the people in your
book you write the tub the United States
cannot wait unaware into Iraq as it once
waited into Vietnam why not we have
focused since 1990 on Iraq only in the
imagery of Saddam Hussein and Saddam
Hussein is a great problem I mean he is
he is a real threat to the Persian Gulf
region but what we haven't thought about
is Iraq itself and this is a country
that was put together by the British at
the end of the first world war really to
meet the British imperial needs and they
brought together people who had
no sense of commonality they were ethnic
groups sectarian groups a tribal groups
and they were then put into this
contrived state and from the very
beginning Iraq has been a very very
tough country to try to govern and now
that you have Saddam Hussein's rule that
he's been there as the sole power for
over 20 years he's stripped the country
of its civil society so that has been
added on to all of these other
fragilities in the country and for the
United States to have the illusion that
we can launch a military operation get
rid of Saddam Hussein pack our bags and
go home is very dangerous because we you
know somebody has got to stay there to
try to help these people get through
this period and it would be a commitment
that could have no end because there is
so much damage done to the country that
was already a very weak country to start
with where is where how did you get into
this well I grew up in the middle of
Oklahoma and there was in my little town
one family of Arab just said which my
father always referred to as the
Assyrians they in retrospect they were
obviously Lebanese I don't know why I in
college I got fascinated with Middle
East and then I went to the University
of Virginia and did graduate studies in
Middle East history and politics Presley
politics and then I sort of took the
mommy track and and had a child and and
was raising him and then in 1978
I went to live in Saudi Arabia well and
my husband was a physician and and went
to work at the king faisal specialist
hospital and I'd always had a hankering
to write and but I didn't think I had
anything to say particularly well
believe me when you're in middle in
Saudi Arabia the middle of the oil boom
and and you have a background in Middle
East Studies you have a lot to to write
about and at the time I had was in my
40s and my husband today still calls me
the grandma moses of journalism but i've
just been at it ever since where do you
live I live in Atlanta and this is what
book for you number five and what were
the other for the first one I wrote was
the Saudis which Norton is bringing out
a new edition of that in October the
second one I did was call Lebanon death
of a nation which was about the Lebanese
civil war my third one was passion
politics which was about the
relationship of the Arabs with each
other not about the arab-israeli dispute
and that my last book prior to this one
was the Iranians Persia Islam in the
soul of a nation one of the things I got
from your book was that they're
constantly different groups against
different groups you have Iran and Iraq
and the Persians and the Arabs and then
even within Saddam Hussein's own within
the curves you have two different groups
and within his own family to different
sons and it goes on and on and on and
you have two different rivers I want to
show this map that you have in the front
of your book and tell us what we're
looking at here all right this is a map
of present-day Iraq and the most
significant feature of it is the fact
that you've got the these two great
rivers the Tigris and the Euphrates
which of course as we all know from our
high school world history of the area
between those two rivers was the cradle
of civilization that we call Mesopotamia
and Iraq is very blessed with resources
and we here oil of course but their
other great resource is his water that
comes from these two rivers it would how
many times you've been there well I was
in and out a lot when i was living in
saudi arabia in from seventy eight to
eighty and then I was in Saudi Arabia
again from 80 to 84 and then I didn't go
back until 98 when I began researching
this book Saddam Hussein was born where
he was born in tick reek which is just
north of Baghdad about 60 miles and he
was born in 1937 he's just turned 65
unfortunately he has no shows no signs
of retiring what was his family like his
family was a what you could almost say
was a typical rural family because
another of the divisions in Iraq that
had been there from the beginning even
as far back as Mesopotamia is the
urban-rural split in the country and his
mother was a tribal woman her family had
migrated from the Arabian Peninsula into
Iraq we don't exactly know when probably
mid 19th century her husband Saddam
Hussein's father died before Saddam
Hussein was born and he was raised by a
very tyrannical stepfather but he was
very much raised in the in the rural
tribal tradition that you find in Iraq
and he intellectually and his experience
he's never really gone beyond that how
did he get into the holes the whole
oh the avenue that got him to be the
head of the country well he had an uncle
that he was sent to live with in Baghdad
he didn't even start his education until
he was 16 years old and I do think you
have to hand it to him that he did
realize you know how important education
was and he I don't think we can question
the fact that he is an intelligent man
whether he's you know well educated is
another issue but he is an intelligent
man and so he went to Baghdad to live
with his uncle who was very much
involved in Arab nationalism in this
political movement that said that the
problems of the Arab world have come
from two things one is we're weighted
down by the traditions of Islam and
secondly the Arabs have been splintered
between all these states that were
created after the First World War and so
what we must do is bring the Arabs
together have one government have a
secular government and then the Arabs
can progress economically politically
and so Saddam Hussein was very much
caught up in fat and it was an ideology
that was promoted by a party called the
bath party and which was originally
founded in Syria during the 40s and then
really had it sort of Haiti there in the
50s and Saddam Hussein really became
what you would call an enforcer for the
bath party he was the wall he was the
street tough who would go out and knock
heads to get to make sure people were
not opposed to bath ideology and
actually he was involved in an
assassination attempt on President
kazeem who well general I'm sorry
general kazeem who was the leader of
Iraq after the revolution of 1950s
and he escaped arrest in that
assassination attempt went to see a to
Egypt and enter cairo university under a
stipend from nasr and then in in 1968 he
returned to iraq and really became the
the principal person who organized the
bass own military regime and very often
people compare saddam hussein to hitler
and that's not the right comparison the
comparison is with stalin because who
saying has a whole library of books on
Stalin and has had studied him very
closely and the reason is because he
sees Stalin as someone who used a
political party to subdue the military
and that's exactly what he has done any
raw he wrote in your book at born in
1937 never in the military lived in chi
Road you just talked about under Nasser
and was obsessed with Stalin what would
that mean part of what you're saying it
seems in the book is that we as a
country don't know anything about Iraq
or Saddam was saying well what we're
about to get into if we go in there and
try to take him out that's right I
really wrote the book from the
standpoint that as little as we know
about Saddam Hussein because he lives at
this you know murky secret world that no
one but those closest to him ever seen
we know even less about Iraq and Iraq is
a very complex country and when you
start talking about dealing with Saddam
Hussein and dealing with Iran is that
you know there is no easy answers there
are only difficult choices in whichever
way we go we get into very big risk and
obviously what has been talked about so
much
nineteen ninety one is the fact that
Saddam Hussein in all probability has
chemical and biological weapons what
we're concerned about is is he going to
get a nuclear weapon and if we leave him
in place you know is that going to be
what happens and is he therefore going
to be able to change the strategic
balance in the Persian Gulf so that's
one that's one risk the other risk is
that the United States invades Iraq on
its own for no other reason than to
change the regime there and all of the
complications that could flow from fat
that that we simply don't understand
because we have never paid attention to
Iraq as a country if you go there first
of how many people live their best guess
right now is about 20 million if you go
to Baghdad what is available in the way
of radio television newspapers what can
the people there read and listen to
nothing this this is one of the great
problems that we've got to deal with is
not only you know do you have to to
build a government if Saddam Hussein is
gone if we take him out you have people
who have been totally isolated from the
world by Saddam Hussein's propaganda
machine and by the sanctions that I mean
the sanctions have contributed greatly
to the isolation of of Iraq and you have
a group of people who have no idea what
is truth what is fiction who is to blame
for for their current economic situation
and they they really have suffered a lot
economically under the sanctions and you
have people who really have no idea how
to deal with the outside world and you
know you are giving to these people then
supposedly a quote democracy
and I think there are some very naive
people who expect that you just simply
remove Saddam Hussein militarily by the
action of the United States and you then
tell the Iraqi people all right now
you're free form a democracy and live
happily ever after have they ever voted
there they have had a some democracy
particularly back during the monarchy
that lasted from 32 to I'm sorry 21 to
58 and the monarchy certainly under the
first king who was feisal and if you
know to help people sort of identify who
he is he's the character Omar Sharif
played in lawrence of arabia and he was
put on the throne of ear off by the
british he was actually from from the
arabian peninsula was not an iraqi
himself but really did put a lot of
effort into trying to develop among all
of these tribes ethnic groups sectarian
groups a sense of iraq as a nation not
just iraq of state because those are two
different things you can have a iraq as
a state today but it's not a nation
because it hasn't developed from people
who have shared interests go back to the
british for a moment how how was the
British how were the British in a
position to even create this country
called a rock well because they had been
victorious in world war one and actually
during the war the British had promised
the Sharif of Mecca who was the father
of feisal that if he would launch a
revolt against Turkey that at the end of
the war they would give him and
arab state that he interpreted is going
from the Persian Gulf to the Nile then
the British got into secret negotiations
with the French that produced something
called the sykes-picot agreement in
which the British in the French had
already divided up the Ottoman Empire's
middle eastern territories before the
war was ever over and so when they went
to Versailles to the peace conference
the British and the French listened to
to the plea of the Arabs for their Arab
state for their national you know to
recognize their nationalism and they
said you know thank you very much it was
nice to hear you your point of view and
then they went in the back room closed
the door rolled out their maps that they
had drawn in the sykes-picot agreements
and divided up the states and what we
now have as Iraq Syria Lebanon what was
Palestine which of course is now largely
Israel and Egypt had already got a jip
was already a British colony so that was
not involved but I think one of the
problems that you've had in the Middle
East not only Iran but these other
countries is that they they are all to a
certain extent contrived countries that
were really thrown into independence
that came at the end of the Second World
War they they got statehood at the First
World War independence Second World War
and we're more or less thrown out there
without any preparation and said all
right you know govern yourselves and
that's one of the reasons they've never
been you know very successful at really
being able to to build viable countries
that have been able to move away from
localism and tribalism and
to really modernize whose idea was it
that they have a monarchy after 1921
well there was a very interesting woman
who was with the British Foreign Office
named gertrude bell and gertrude bell
was a scholar of that era area and had
really traveled a lot and knew the
tribes better than anybody did and so
she was one that felt that the Iraqis
had to have a strong hand at the tail
and she certainly was in agreement with
other people in the british foreign
policy establishment who felt that you
know the model for iraq should be the
model of monarchy which is what Britain
had and so that was what led to a and
and the choice of a feisal came about
because of this failed promises to his
his father and the British really took
the oldest son two older sons of the
Sharif of Mecca and put one on the
throne in a Damascus which was feisal
and the other one on the throne and what
became Jordan it was abdullah the
grandfather of late King Hussein and
then the the bread the French through
feisal out of Syria and he wound up on
the doorstep of the British in London
and they thought oh we've got you know
we got to do something with his bed and
so the idea of creating a government for
Iraq and needing to fulfill a promise to
the family of the Sharif of Mecca they
sent him to Baghdad so in 58 what
happened to the monarchy the monarchy
was overthrown by a military to and I
think this is one of the real
unfortunate episodes in Iran's history
because
the monarchy probably was the best
government they ever had now certainly
it had its faults it had its
shortcomings but particularly during the
50s when Iran began to develop
economically the monarchy really did
think about how you were going to
develop not only Iran's oil but how you
were going to develop its our
agriculture and how you were really
going to try to somewhat equalize the
economic system their problems were that
they were too interested in protecting
the rights of the Sunni minority these
are Arabic speaking Sunni Muslims who
have always been roughly twenty percent
of the population four million people
out of the 20 million would be Sunnis
right and what is Saddam Hussein Saddam
Hussein is a Sunni and the Sunnis have
always been the political and economic
elite of Iraq and it actually started
with the Ottomans because the Ottomans
being Sunnis themselves and being
concerned with the rival Shia in Iran
always put of power in the hands of the
Sunnis in in Baghdad and when
independence came that gets carried over
to the British who want to keep things
stable and they want to keep the
existing system operating so they also
gave all the prerogatives to the Shia I
be I'm sorry to the Sunni now what if i
had a Sunni sitting here with us and a
Shiite sitting here could you tell the
difference of looking at him ah probably
not if you had a Clary two clerics you
could because the shia clerics
us differently than the Sunni clerics
but as long as they're arabic-speaking
you know that they are very much the
same people because they all had their
origins in the Arabian Peninsula and the
reason that you have Sunnis and Shia in
Iraq in the Arab population is that when
these migrations occurred in the late
19th century they the people who were in
charge of the major Shia shrines in Iraq
which is no Jeff and Carvallo or
Persians I had they had come from Iran
and they controlled those areas and they
were feeling that they needed to have
some power on the ground some military
power and so they actually went out as
missionaries to these Arab tribes who
were coming into Mesopotamia and
actually made alliances with him which
very often were political alliances or
economic alliances and the third thing
they did was they address the tribal
Arabs sort of crisis of identity of
moving from nomadism to settle farmers
in this very rich agricultural area so
those three things combined together
that resulted in the split of the
rural-urban I mean the rural Arab
population between the Shia and the
Sunni how do you keep track all this
well I study it every day what's been
mean how long have you studied this well
about 30 years and what value did it
have when he does it have when you go
over there when you're actually on the
scene in Iran or Iraq and if you have
you been to Jordan and Syria and oh yes
I've been in all of those countries I
you go with I think a real cultural
sensitivity
and I have found that i have not had
problems working in this area that so
many people say oh you must have this
problem because you're a woman and I say
no quite the contrary that I think being
a woman working this area is an
advantage one thing is that I think men
sometimes don't take you maybe seriously
enough as far as what your intellectual
level is or what your expertise is but
even more important is that you get to
go into the world of the women and they
really know what's going on and they'll
tell you the men tend to be very close
lip about you know what's going on
politically but the women aren't and you
find out an enormous amount how much
when did Iraq discover their oil it was
early 20th century I I don't recall the
exact date but they knew there was oil
in Iran as in as early as 1904 and so it
just made scientific sense that there
was oil and Iraq and so it was really
after the autumn fall of the Ottoman
Empire that you know the oil then began
to become a factor Ottoman Empire was
what the Ottoman Empire was the empire
that was put together from Istanbul over
several centuries starting in the 14th
century and it was probably completed
well it was at its height in the 16th
century under Suleiman the Magnificent
and then the Ottoman Empire through a a
series of their own missteps and
mismanagement began to fall apart I mean
it sort of you know different areas
would break away and you know the famous
phrase before the First World War that
Ottoman Empire was the sick man of
Europe that everybody realized that it
was was falling apart and that it
probably could not survive the war and
of course it didn't it fell apart with
the armistice and as we've said that's
when you then had the boundaries of
modern Middle East drawn in the Iraq
area and all those surrounding countries
how many folks over there are Sunnis and
how many are Shiites the vast majority
are Sunni and that and and the Sunnis
are the Orthodox Muslims the there's
probably about ten percent she will
probably not that much in the Arab world
over all about ten percent of Muslims
are arshiya so then Iraq is unusual very
unusual there is a concentration of Arab
Shia in southern Lebanon there are some
settlements of Shia in on the eastern
coast of Saudi Arabia in Bahrain all of
those countries on the Persian Gulf have
some Shia population but the great Shia
population is non arab and that of
course is in iran so what about the
infrastructure of saddam hussein's
government made up of how many sunni
versus how many shia the leadership the
military well you know it's it's very
hard to know what goes on because as I
say things are so are so tight but what
Saddam Hussein did after the gulf war to
save himself was that he just gave up on
this whole idea of trying to build an e
rocky nation because you know in
fairness to the bass during the 70's
during the oil boom they really did make
an attempt to bring everybody into a
what was essentially a socialist system
albeit the fact that it was totally can
troll by the bath party after the Gulf
War and Saddam Hussein had faced these
two rebellions the Shia in the south
rose against him the Kurds in the north
rose against him and the reason he
survived that was that the Sunnis in the
center and they're the people who are in
the military decided that no matter how
bad they thought Saddam Hussein was the
Sunnis hated the idea of the Shia maybe
being able to take over as a majority of
the country and so they gathered behind
Saddam Hussein it was enough military
power to put down both of these
rebellions since then Saddam Hussein has
not really operated on trying to bring
these groups into the government to try
to balance the political power and the
economic prerogatives what he's done is
he has gone into each of these groups
and he has plucked out tribal leaders
and made alliances with them and how the
thing works is that he gives them arms
and money and they patrol their
populations and the most ordinary of
these tribal alliances are with
traditional tribes and some of the
tribes are Kurds some of them are Sunnis
a lot of Mercia and he's added to that
what are what we might call neo tribes
and he will get like of the metal
workers in Baghdad in a certain section
organized not as like a union but as a
tribal unit and that they will be a try
by occupation as opposed to a tribe by
kinship and he's just replicated this
over and over and over throughout the
country and he controls here on through
these tribal groups in Iraq ever have
28 years ago no they they wanted to they
they made a you know they claim Kuwait
as a part of Iraq and certainly did that
in the Gulf when the invasion took place
they called it the 19th province of Iraq
and their claim really goes back to the
fact that the they said the Ottomans
included Kuwait in what was called in
Mesopotamia how much of that whole area
that we showed in that map earlier
belonged to the Ottoman Empire at one
time the entire area if you get to the
northern part of Saudi Arabia the
Ottoman Empire really went from the
border of Iran across the whole Fertile
Crescent until you got to Egypt but that
it swung up into the Balkans and then
you had some of the Ottoman Empire of
course what's down Turkey and in that
arc there so the Ottoman Empire was
quite large and every country in the
Middle East now with the exception of
the countries on the Arabian Peninsula
were part of the Ottoman Empire what do
you see when you go to Iraq that we
don't see through television um I don't
think it's what you see it's what you
feel and you really feel this horrible
horrible repression of people you you
you sense the fear of people and
certainly a level of desperation which
that level of desperation maybe has
eased a little bit because the sanctions
have both been raveling and secondly
we've revised the sanctions regime
regimen so the sanctions are not quite
as tough i would say more than anything
you just feel iraq is
a incredibly unhappy place how much oil
do we buy this country by from the
Iraqis ah they are producing now about
four million barrels a day and we are
buying um it seems to belie I haven't
checked the last few weeks but I we're
getting you know somewhere around ten
percent of our oil imports from me raw
there was a statement made a couple of
days ago by Senator Murkowski that we're
getting a million a day that wouldn't
surprise me because it will go up and
down four billion dollars a year
spending in Iraq mm-hmm we are still
bombing Iraq and the North and the South
and over that trying to take out
different missile sites explain all this
well the United States in 1991 that made
the decision not to go to Baghdad with
with good reason because we're talking
we face the same situation in 91 that
we're facing now once you invade Iraq
it's like the tar baby you know you
really don't know what you're going to
get into secondly we didn't go because
the coalition that george bush senior
belt one of the one of the promises made
to the arab states that joined was that
we would not invade and occupy arab
territory that we would get saddam
hussein out of kuwait and that was going
to be the operation so it was a very
defined exact operation then you know
the feeling was that Saddam Hussein
would fall within a period of weeks
months at the most because no one that
was as hated as he was by his people you
know quote could survive such a
humiliating military defeat well Saddam
Hussein showed that not only you know he
might not know how to operate outside
his boundaries but he really understood
erock and as I said with
his sunni control military he was able
to you know hold himself in power and
then the United States realized that if
we weren't going to get rid of him we
had to control his weapons of mass
weapons not not just mass destruction we
wanted to get rid of his conventional
forces in his his missiles and
everything and so that was what
originated as the as the armed you know
the arms embargo against he well it was
a total embargo against Iraq under the
auspices of the United Nations and every
time Saddam Hussein would make a move
that would threaten one part of the
country are another the United States
would for lack of anything else they do
to do was to set up a no-fly zone the
first one was with the Kurds because the
Kurds really did suffer a great deal and
their rebellion and the advantage they
had over the Shia who had rebelled first
was that the international press could
come in over the borders of Turkey and
Iran and really see what was happening
and so there was a great public outcry
that the United States had to do
something to protect these Kurdish
refugees so that was the first no-fly
zone then later subsequently when Saddam
Hussein appeared to be moving back south
that then we set up a similar no-fly
zone over the south and so that means
that there is a band across the center
of Iraq that is underneath is not under
the no-fly zone and what's been going on
is that Saddam Hussein challenges those
no-fly zones all the time by sending
missiles against these planes that are
patrolling them and then we come in and
we bomb these installations so this
fort ad has been going on for the last
decade what would happen if we stopped
buying their oil probably nothing except
that maybe oil prices would would go up
but if they're in a market that if we
don't take it somebody else is going to
take it doesn't make that much
difference because we always say you
know well we you know why worry about
the Persian Gulf because we only get
seventeen percent of our oil from the
Persian Gulf well true but you don't
really figure out where you're getting
your oil imports because what determines
the price is how much is going into the
International pipeline so if for
instance this is why we have to worry so
much about the stability of the Persian
Gulf because while we maybe get
seventeen percent of our oil from the
gulf Japan gets something of the range
of eighty percent Europe gets an
enormous amount of their oil and if you
destabilize that area and you interrupt
interrupt the production of oil then
that's when you really start having big
economic problems because the oil prices
are just going to go are going to
escalate because you've taken a huge
portion of the oil out of the market o
is what you're saying that by us by a
million barrels a day offense what it is
out of Iraq that we that money is going
to building the weapons of mass
destruction well actually what we're
buying from Iraq is quote legal oil and
in 1996 because of the enormous
suffering of the Iraqi people the
Security Council united nations adopted
the oil-for-food programme which they
had actually offered to Saddam Hussein
in 1991 and he refused so that the first
five years of Iraqi suffering under the
sanctions was no one's fault that Saddam
Hussein's
um but in in 96 he things got so
desperate that he accepted the
oil-for-food under that program the
sanctions committee tell z rock you can
produce x barrels of oil in this quarter
of know if this six months it goes on
six months basis and with the proceeds
of that money we will by the UN food and
medicine for the Iraqi people and we
will pay reparations to Kuwait and when
the inspector the arms inspectors were
in Iraq pay for administering that
program and so the money that we are
paying for Iraqi oil is not going to his
his weapons of mass destruction that's
going actually for food medicine under
oil for food so what happens if we
attack there say you know there's all
kinds of scenarios that 200,000 troops
were involved and we went in to try to
take him out and his government out what
would happen and try to go around the
horn quickly in Iran what would their
reaction be Iran would be very unhappy
because they consider the Persian Gulf
their front door they're very
nationalistic they're very suspicious of
the United States trying to reinvent REE
but probably nothing serious would
happen a lot of rhetoric but nothing
serious what would be the reaction of
the people in Syria the people in Syria
also I think they would make a lot of
noise about the United States but uh
militarily they they're in no position
to do anything and I baby you know the
question is how much control does the
government have over its people and
probably enough to keep the lid on how
many people live in Surrey oh you would
ask me that I haven't looked at the
figures but i would say around 20 20
million what would be the reaction of
the people in saudi arabia all right now
this is where we really have to start
getting worried because American foreign
policy since 1973 and this is policy in
the Persian Gulf has been based on one
thing and that is to guarantee the
movement of oil at reasonable prices and
what we're facing with a unilateral
invasion of Iraq is blowing the lid off
of the political situation in Saudi
Arabia Jordan and Egypt Egypt of course
is not a major oil producer nor is
Jordan but these are all countries that
have been very friendly with the United
States they've been very cooperative
with us they've done us a lot of favors
we've done them a lot of favors it's
been a mutual alliance but those
governments are really becoming less and
less able to keep the lid on their
populations we in the trade refer to it
as the Arab Street which you mean means
the non elites and if you would have
which i think is a very real risk we
have to think about Saudi Arabia
destabilized and you know it all don't
tell me what's going to you know happen
I mean we we can defeat Saddam Hussein
that's not the problem it's stabilizing
the situation to keep oil production
going there and and we start really
getting into problems of interrupted
production in the Persian Gulf then
we're all going to pay a big economic
price 20 million people in Iraq what's
the age breakdown Oh vast majority under
20 you know it's again one of these
countries that like most of the Arab
countries you know they have got to
control population that's their biggest
problem that regardless of how much oil
they have
how much foreign assistance they have
how much economic development they try
to do they simply cannot keep up with
the population growth are they trainable
I mean can you go in there with a cadre
of people that speak the language and
all that and teach them democracy um
sure I mean it's in fact you know we
look at saudi arabia's being a very
authoritarian regime and it is but it's
not an autocratic regime and there's
always been in Saudi Arabia a a
relationship between the house of south
and the various segments of the
population and you know you're not
necessarily going to just say you know
here's western-style democracy we want
you to adopt that they've got to find
their own way but but certainly they can
learn democracy because in many ways
they have daman you know they have a a
type of democracy that we just don't
understand how it works go back to your
your conclusion that you brought Vietnam
into this if you also said in your
conclusion that read it again an
invasion of Iraq has become almost a
given in the unfolding war on terrorism
so it's going to happen I'm afraid it is
you don't like the idea I don't like it
at all I think it depends you know it
really depends on how it happens I mean
if if Saddam Hussein really does get a
nuclear weapon he then changes the
strategic balance in the Gulf and I
think we can get people to get on board
with us and to get a multilateral
invasion of Iraq that's a whole
different scenario I think that could
happen without as many ramifications as
going in alone secondly if Saddam
Hussein would die for instance or if he
would be
overthrown and you had just total chaos
descend on the country then I think the
United States could go in again as part
of a multilateral force to try to bring
some stability what I worry about is
just going in and doing it alone and
having to take on our shoulders the
whole responsibility of trying to put
Humpty Dumpty back together again the
Iraqis have have never been able to
really bring themselves together to you
know to have a common vision the
politics there even in the best of times
has been one in which a rival group
refuses to give in to the needs of rival
group and and and to reach some sort of
consensus so having said all that what
part of your book is the most important
to understand what could happen if we go
in there I think the most important part
of it to understand is really beginning
with the founding of the state and this
lack of any common sense of identity and
it's just gone on decade after decade
government after government and it has
just been exacerbated under Saddam
Hussein by really reviving tribalism
this picture is from where that's the
parade ground and that is the monument
to the iraq-iran war which lasted eight
years and killed probably a million
people on together on both sides you say
that those arms of the hands on the side
are supposed to be Saddam Hussein's
that's the rumor that they were were
sculpted from a picture of his four arms
have you been on this parade gronau i
have in fact I almost got arrested they
are trying to go to his birthday party
why would why we did you almost get
arrested well I I was there on his
birthday
they were having a big celebration of at
the parade ground and I just decided
that I would walk over and see what was
going on and I was cutting across an
area that was not very well left and I
stepped across one of these grates that
that has the prongs that stick up yet so
he can't drive over it soon as I stepped
on the other side all of these flood
lights came on and a soldier had a gun
on me and told me not to move and he
summoned the secret police and they
arrived in one of their ominous white
Toyota's and I thought oh I have done it
now you know I am off to jail and this
is again where it really does pay to be
a woman because they told me to get in
the car and I just you know rose up in
righteous indignation if I said no you
know I you know how dare you you know
you expect me a respectable woman to get
in a car with men i'm not related to now
mind you i was scared to death what i
said that you're by yourself I was by
myself and how do you know what to do
you know I mean obviously they could
have just you know manhandled me and put
me in it well again they told me you
know to get in took the rifles and
pointed at me and told me get in the car
and I said no and I pulled out my card
they gave you at the hotel and it's the
AL Rasheed hotel that most foreigners
are required to stay there and if you're
there they know you're there with the
permission of the government and I said
you know I am at the AL Rasheed I am
going back to my hotel and I turned
around and just started walking back to
the hotel and they followed me all the
way back and as soon as I walked into
the gate of the hotel well then they
turned around and left because every
person who works at the hotels
part of the secret police so they knew I
was you know would be observed so anyway
it was it was a frightening experience
what's the greatest source of material
for you in writing this book um yeah I
always think my greatest source is the
people I talked to and you know that was
as I say was frustrating inside Iraq you
had to do a lot of the interviews with
people outside Iraq but I also I think
that it's just sitting down and really
looking at the tragedy of Iraq from from
day one it's it's a it's a sad story
it's a it's a sad country and you know
it's not going to be any better for a
while at least after Saddam Hussein is
gone they have lots of problems lots of
wounds that have got to be healed
unfortunately we're out of time here's
what the book looks like it's called The
Reckoning Iraq and the legacy of Saddam
Hussein our guest has been Sandra Mackey
and we thank you very much thank you